we saw Aquaman and tracked down all the
sunken Easter Egg treasures just for you
let's take a deep dive so you may have
noticed if you watched Aquaman that
there's a ton going on in this movie it
remixes and mashes up all sorts of
elements of the classic Aquaman lore but
a lot of the main plot threads including
all the stuff about the original king of
Atlantis at land was inspired by throne
of Atlantis a 2013 comic book storyline
written by DC films mastermind Geoff
Johns the character of at land was first
introduced to Aquaman comics in the
1970s but he became a really important
figure after Aquaman's backstory was
reworked for DC's new 52 era these
comics introduced a lot of stuff about
the quest for at land's trident and orms
planned war with the surface world that
we see realized on screen in the film it
was also adapted into a pretty solid
animated movie back in 2015 while we're
talking trident remember when volcko
says that the king's trident is made out
of poseidon metal by retrieving this
arrows like this one you don't this is a
deep cut for all the DC fans in the
crowd in the comics all the metal
weapons used by gods are made of what's
called a 'the metal wonder woman's comic
book bracers are also a 'the metal
there's also a ninth metal tube but they
call it an 'the metal cuz you know why
not of course Aquaman's long time
octopus sidekick topo had to make it
into the film as well that's him in the
black light paint playing the drums
during the big horn versus Arthur
Coliseum faceoff yes in the comics he
knows how to play several musical
instruments
that's cannon and let's talk about dr.
Steven shin who's played in the film by
Randall Park
he's the surface world's leading expert
on Atlantis which I guess is not really
saying that much because the surface
world just discovered Atlantis like a
few days ago dr. Shen first appeared
Ngoc man number two all the way back in
2011 when we first see dr. Shen he's on
a TV panel discussion show talking about
metahumans this itself is kind of a
shout out to an ongoing DC film's
continuity in Batman V Superman the
existence of metahumans was still
considered theoretical by scientists and
researchers but now in Aquaman a parent
they've been confirmed probably that
whole Superman dying and being
resurrected thing hard to be skeptical
when a guy comes back to life and
develops a weird computer-animated upper
lip in the mid-credits sequence
featuring doctor shin getting to know
Black Manta careful viewers may have
noticed his collection of newspaper
clippings about Aquaman which are
hanging up on the walls a few of the
clippings also referenced Wonder Woman
so we know he's keeping an eye on her as
well and one is from the newspaper the
coast city ledger ko City is the town
where Green Lantern Hal Jordan resides
could this mean Green Lantern will
finally be introduced into the DC movie
universe but director James Wan wasn't
content to just fill his movie with
references to DC Comics he's riffing on
a whole world of undersea related pop
culture when Arthur's dad Tom first
rescues at Lana and brings her into his
home we see he's reading a copy of HP
Lovecraft story the Dunwich horror it's
about a boy who was born to a human
mother and a monstrous
inhuman father yeah born of two worlds
at one point during a training exercise
Arthur dismissively refers to his
instructor volcko as Cobra Kai
this of course references the villainous
dojo from the 80s classic The Karate Kid
seems like kind of a dated reference for
Arthur who was born a few years after
Karate Kid was a box-office hit maybe he
caught up with the YouTube series in a
nod to his iconic conjuring series Wan
placed a tiny hard to spot Easter Egg in
one of the underwater sequences while
Mara and Arthur are boarding her ship
you can briefly see the Annabelle doll
from the conjuring films abandoned on
the sea floor
well I mean I guess that's one way to
get rid of her and finally in that
mid-credits sequence we see black manta
being rescued at sea while floating on
top a straight plank in a shot eerily
reminiscent of James Cameron's Titanic
sea guys only room for one person on
that plank and that's every little thing
we found sifting for two and a half
hours of Aquaman action no hot
crustacean bands but still a lot of good
stuff maybe it wasn't everything though
if you dredged up any awesome little
jokes or references we missed splash on
over to the comments and okay I'll stop
I promise
[Applause]